consider the density curve below and
this density curve doesn't look like the
ones we typically see that are a little
bit curvier but this is a little easier
for us to work with and figure out areas
and so they asked us to find the percent
of the area under the density curve
where X is more than two so what area
represents when X is more than two so
this is when X is equal to two so
they're talking about this area right
over here and so we need to figure out
the percent of the total area under the
curve that this blue area actually
represents so first let's find the total
area under the density curve and the
density only has area the density curve
only has area from x equals 1 to x
equals 3 so it does amount to form
finding the area of this larger
trapezoid let me highlight this
trapezoid in red so we want to find the
area of this trapezoid right over here
and then that should be equal to 1
because all density curves have an area
of 1 under the total curve so let's
first verify that so there's a couple of
ways to think about it we could split it
up into two shapes or you could just use
the formula for an area of a trapezoid
so let's use the formula for an area of
a trapezoid the formula for an area of a
trapezoid is you take the average of you
would take the average of this length we
do that in another color this length and
this length and then multiply that times
the base so the average of this length
and this length let's see this is 0.25
0.25 Plus this height 0.75 divided by 2
so that's the average of those two sides
times the base times this right over
here which is 2 and so this is going to
give us as it should have 0.25 plus 0
point seven five which is equal to one
so the area under the entire density
curve is one which we need to be true
for this to be a density curve now let's
think about what percentage of that area
is represented in blue right over here
well we could do the same thing we could
say alright this is a trapezoid we want
to take the average of this side and
this side and multiply it times the base
so this side is 0.5 hi 0.5 plus 0.75
0.75 hi and we're going to take the
average of that divided by 2 times the
base well the base going from 2 to 3 is
only equal to is equal to 1 so x 1 and
so this is going to give us one point
two five one point two five over two and
what is that going to be equal to well
that would be the same thing as zero
point what let's see 0.625 do I do that
right yep if I multiply 2 times this I
would get one point two five so the
percent of the area under the density
curve where X is more than two this is
the decimal expression of it if we
wanted to write it as a percent it would
be sixty two point five percent let's do
another example consider the density
curve below all right we have another
one of these somewhat angular density
curves find the percent of the area
under the density curve where X is more
than three so we're talking about see
this is where X is equal to three X is
more than three we're talking about this
entire area right over here well this is
actually somewhat straightforward
because if we're saying the area where X
is more than three that's the entire
area under the density curve and the
entire area under any density curve
needs to be equal to one or you could
say find the percent of the area under
that have to control the whole density
curve is
where X is more than three so 100% we
don't even have to go through the
trouble of trying to directly calculate
the area